after the last couple of months that
after eight entire videos I could
finally take a breath and proudly say to
myself that I finally seen everything I
felt proud of myself for not having
given up for seeing the arduous journey
through to the bitter end it got hard
people called me a fraud for never
having seen them all but now now I can
proudly stand the top the dynasty of my
own creation and finally declare I have
seen everything
Dragon Ball has ever made and that is
until reality slapped me and screamed
into my face my way and there most
definitely is more five more in fact
today we will be finally putting the
last stamp and posting the last reviews
for these old Dragon Ball TV specials
and OVA s today we will be taking a look
at plan to eradicate the sames from 1993
and 2010 episode of Bardock from 2011
dream 9 Torico one piece and DBZ super
collaboration crossover from 2013 which
let's face it is probably the most
catchy title today's and finally yo son
goku and his friends returned from 2008
let's get this show on the road so I can
finally relax
first one up yo son Goku and his friends
return release date September 21st 2008
length approximately 35 minutes and the
concept of this story was written by
Akira Toriyama the story itself takes
place roughly 2 years after the events
of Dragon Ball Z but before Dragon Ball
super so let's get into it I actually
really enjoyed this for what it was it's
a simple story not meant to be taken
super seriously it's lighthearted and
tone and delivers pretty much on that
premise the OVA itself features an
entirely reanimated opening sequence
with the classic Dragon Ball Z theme Sun
Chawla head chala the best things about
this reanimated opening are pretty much
the selling point of this entire ova
short story nostalgia the Opie is
reanimated entirely but is intentionally
storyboarded to match the classic
version complete with an updated cast of
characters post Buu saga the story
itself begins proper as two space pods
are seen making their way towards Earth
before we catch up with Goku and his
friends as they go about their
day-to-day lives it's revealed that mr.
Satan will be throwing a small
get-together for those that helped
defeat majin buu to celebrate the
opening of his new hotel goku isn't
exactly sold on the idea of attending
until go on himself says that there will
be an all-you-can-eat section for goku
personally goku then decides it's a
worthwhile event to attend this is
hilarious because someone liking food is
funny in anime and so we cut to the
party where we meet the rest of the
classic cast including trunks piccolo
and Vegeta among others it's at this
point we are introduced to Vegeta's
little brother Tarble now I don't like
Tarble I think he's a terrible idea
personally I think he creates more
problems for the series and is needed I
get that this is a bit of fun and it is
fun but Tarble is relentless in his
insistence on being canon despite us all
try our best to forget about it but we
can't forget about him because he's
mentioned in passing more than literally
any other character in this series with
comparable screen time regardless he
makes his debut in this short story as
he arrives to warn the gang of some
enemies coming and Goku uses this as an
opportunity to show him Super Saiyan the
visual style itself is something that
also has been updated since the end of
Dragon Ball GT featuring toyoshima
Morrow's 2008 character designs my
favorite aspect of this aesthetic change
has to be its choice of color and
minimalist one tone shading and that's
not to even mention the Super Saiyan
color scheme that finally makes the hair
Amit
a mystical golden glow a sight from that
in the end the group decides amongst
themselves who gets to fight the
invaders by picking radishes and
ultimately trunks wins the draw but
Goten gets to join in as he was the
runner-up and there are two opponents
there's actually some nice animation
during this battle sequence and
interesting move sets on display to
country the two young Saints ultimately
the story focuses a lot on the
light-hearted slice of life site of
Dragon Ball and I honestly really liked
that in the end everyone gets to have
their shot against the big bad before
ending it all in one nostalgic upbeat
note it's a very fun short and nostalgic
look back at the franchise we all grew
up with and I'm sure when it was
released that feeling was even more
potent
next up planned to eradicate the Saiyans
from 1993 and 2010 each one having a
varied runtime it's sort of complicated
these were two short stories made for
different video games and the newer of
the two is a modern recreation of sorts
the older one is from 1993 and the newer
version is from 2010 let's check out the
old one first this older version is
split into two parts and begins with the
bad guys stating his motivations to the
camera he hates what the sands have done
and thus he wants to eradicate the sands
on earth we then cut to earth as mr.
Popo announces to Gohan and Goku that
this gas is destroying life on the
planet and that within seventy days even
likely beings like themselves would be
done for with this slightly depressing
news they venture to bomas whereby they
devised a plan to seek out and destroy
the source of the gas however before
they leave a group of aliens begin to
attack and this is where things start to
get a little interesting because of the
nature of the gas the key that Goku and
the others used to fight has been
rendered useless thankfully they can
still punch and kick but I thought this
was interesting because it's in some way
in the same vein as the current arc
that's being written in the Dragon Ball
super manga implemented by Mauro with
that said the rest of the middle section
is spent with Goku Gohan and piccolo all
individually going through various parts
of earth and destroying the sources of
the gas upon arrival while beating up
the grunts defending it I think this is
fun for some decent action scenes but I
think it works perhaps a bit better as a
cutscene at times I felt that was
missing some context for instance the
first scene follows Goku into the
mountains as he fails to use his key
this is followed immediately after by
Gohan who common
that his key is coming back just like
his dad said I never heard Goku say this
and so it sort of makes me feel like I'm
only seeing half of the story
eventually Future Trunks and Vegeta
joined the action before all the classic
movie and manga villains start to
reappear freezing a cooler Lord slug et
cetera however fighting the classic
villains proves to be a worthless effort
and so King Kai chimes in to inform them
that they need to attack the source a
person by the name of dr. right chief
there's genuinely some fantastic combat
animation in the second half and it's
definitely worth checking out
the story itself climaxes as Goku and
the gang finally locate the doctor and
actually get some great hits in but not
before the doctor takes on his true form
and causes some more trouble for the
heroes of the story the design of this
doctor right she's final form is okay I
guess but I'm not totally sold on it
either for some reason it reminds me of
a less cool version of Geneva but that's
a minor criticism efest they eventually
defeat the big bad by heating him super
hard and go lay on the grass for a while
and now the 2010 version the latest
version of this story ignoring the TFS
one is half the runtime but works a bit
better as a story I guess while the
prior had far superior visuals I believe
this one doesn't feel like it was
missing any part of the story it didn't
feel like I was watching a cutscene but
an actual episode of a show with that
said neither of these felt as good as
the TV show itself in my opinion but
neither were that bad either they both
share pretty much the exact same story
but the 1993 version provides more
mini-bosses I guess for lack of a better
term and side quests before compounding
the big bad at the end the newer 2010
version is much more streamlined but
features possibly the most unappealing
version of the Dragon Ball art style I
could envision personally my eyes are
honestly still burning from the super
saturated colors nothing really feels
like it's textured and feels very flat
and cheap to me but it is available in
high resolution and if you're a fan of
this style then this one is the option
for you I don't really have anything
else more to add for this version it's
really just a retelling of the same
story of just shorter the second-to-last
Dragon Ball Story I'll be tackling today
is the episode of Bardock from 2011 and
thankfully this one is only 20 minutes
long so I guess I don't need to explain
very much okay maybe I need to explain a
few things the episode begins as we are
acquainted with the closing moments of
Bardock the father of Goku before
throwing us and
into the future where these little
purple blob monsters live they are very
annoying
Bardock doesn't really know that he's in
the past and finds himself defending
this small civilization from evildoers
and this weird-looking unitard wearing
Frieza thing overall I'm really not a
fan of this style of animation I think
they took a lot of liberties with
paradox establish character from the 90s
special and I think the setting for this
entire story is honestly very annoying I
would imagine the impetus for this story
was that one of the editors or writers
had an idea to make Goku's father the
legendary Super Saiyan through insane
circumstances and I'm not saying that
can't work there are ways to make the
craziest ideas work but this certainly
wasn't it for me there's a nice little
bit of interesting animation towards the
end that I enjoy despite once again this
being my least enjoyable Dragonball art
style I think this works best as a
poorly executed high budget one if story
but honestly not without it's redeemable
attributes here and there if you're
bored and feel like some mindless action
with an interesting but poorly
thought-out concept my next and last
review for this video comes in the form
of Dream 9 Torico and one piece and
direct Dragon Ball Z super collaboration
special god that's an awful title and
it's the weirdest thing I've ever seen
no that might sound like hyperbole but I
swear it's not buckle up because we're
in for one hell of a ride with this one
alright so this one came out around 2013
and is roughly 47 minutes in length the
special features three intellectual
properties Dragonball one piece and
Torico storico for the vast majority of
those out there was a relatively recent
TV show on Fuji TV I'm guessing the
purpose behind this special was to
create a sense that torco was on the
same level as one piece and Dragonball
which it wasn't
leave us to say Torico eventually
relinquished the time slot to unfuck
Eevee to what later became Dragonball
super time slot which ran for three
years now that we know what Torico is
let's dive into this mess the story
itself starts with a cold open at the
international gourmet organizations
tastiest under the heavens tournament
yep the announcer describes what's up to
be worn and without describing the rules
itself for the tournament he says began
and literally everyone in the crowd
starts running running where I have no
idea is it a race maybe it sure looks
that way
but there's no time to think because
suddenly an enormous level 40 beetle
shows up and creates a massive sinkhole
sucking up 99% of the contestants
shockingly however the contestants
remaining are from the three IPS
supporting this production and boy howdy
are they still running once the title
drops eventually the rules are explained
it's a freestyle race that doesn't allow
flying and whomever reaches the stadium
in the island Center wins okay so it's a
race but there's shenanigans sort of I'm
imagining something like Wacky Races but
without the cars the remaining runners
are suddenly faced with a split
three-way decision I'm glad they made
the decision to make the three main
characters take the same path as having
them interact I guess is the entire
point of this production it also helps
focus the three separate groups into
three distinct locations which adds
variety the special itself follows the
other groups with Gohan and Goten before
eventually arriving back at Goku Luffy
and Torico as they summit the mountain
King Kai however has bad news for Goku
apparently some evil has appeared in
space
Goku immediately instant transmissions
out of there before later cutting back
to Luffy and Torico as they approach the
finishing area it's at this moment Goku
comes rampaging through after having
saves the earth catching up to both
characters with what seems to be
relative ease however all three land at
the finishing point at the exact same
time in order to decide the victor they
hold a fighting tournament between Goku
Torico and Luffy with ringer or forfeit
being the only ways of elimination
all three exchanged blows using iconic
maneuvers that they are famous for but
it quickly becomes clear that with all
three having their reputation on the
line none of them are really going to
win or lose and so it ends in a draw
well not really a draw after the final
attack between the three characters mr.
Satan is by pure circumstance the only
one left in the ring I'm not sure how
this works but I'm not questioning it he
wins I guess the second half of the
special sees everyone feasting on the
main prize that they were all fighting
for a special meat prize that is until a
monster appears from the water
the monster fish thing
orbs the life force of a number of
prominent characters before the big
final fight of the special takes place
all three fighters and teams joined
forces to tackle this one big foe a lot
of characters become involved with this
there's a ton of fanservice with plenty
of team-ups Super Saiyan 3 power-ups
fusions and spear bombs this is a
special entirely dedicated to fanservice
and if you're a fan of at least two of
the three shows on display here I think
it could be a fun watch for you just
don't expect it to have a conclusive
Victor because it largely won't though I
would say that there's a slight bias
towards Dragon Ball in this special and
that's it I'm finally done there's
literally no more I've spoken about the
original Dragon Ball series in my
anatomy of anime I reviewed every Dragon
Ball movie and completed the OVA s and
specials from the past and my entire
channel has been almost exclusively
covering Dragon Ball super there's not a
single thing left
[Music]